this will not be my campaign this will  be our campaign all together the the  piece of rhetoric there that's really  really important is Trump answering his  critics who say you're a narcissist and  everything's about you and Trump is  saying it's not about me this is about  you and it's about us together it  hearkens back to that really brilliant  moment of rhetoric in the 2016 campaign  when Hillary had unveiled her motto I'm  with her  and he said I'm with her uh-uh that's  not my motto I'm with you that's my  motto  totally changes the subject even of that  motto  for Hillary the subject was all these  little peasants are just you know uh  paying obeisance  and pledging fealty to her her majesty  Hillary and with Trump he says no no  it's my campaign and I'm saying look I  am with you and the campaign even though  I'm the one running it it's really all  about you and